the inspiring story of one person who
fought to break down barriers and just
made her debut on Broadway we're talking
about RuPaul's Drag Race winner Jinx
Monsoon who's starring in the Musical
Chicago Christina raffini met her at the
Historical Stonewall Inn here in New
York City to talk about gender blind
casting her journey to sobriety and how
a little magic might help even the most
jaded Among Us
are you ready it's gonna be kind of
cuckoo banana crackers Jinx Monsoon
knows how to make an exit
foreign
gets a signature then everyone gets a
photo you just have to stick around
but it's her entrance into the high
stakes eight shows a week world of
Broadway
[Applause]
ask any of the chickies in my pen that
has audiences doing well this
that's very surreal and incredible to me
I'm somewhere I never expected to be as
a scrappy Dive Bar drag queen you know
this month Jinx premiered as Mama Morton
in the Ambassador theater's production
of Chicago there's no wink wink nod nod
with your casting you are just casting a
roll and that's it the fact that I got
my Broadway debut and in fulfilling a
mission statement of mine to show the
world that it doesn't matter
the gender identity of the human being
playing the character all that matters
is that you get the character
and character has always been at the
core of jinx monsoon
she got her start at 15 performing drag
in her hometown of Portland but she
always wanted to be on the somewhat more
traditional stage so she began
auditioning for and Landing female roles
it's in all the magazines at the time
then in 2012 she landed on the popular
reality show RuPaul's Drag Race Jinx
monsoon
initially an underdog she won her season
then was invited back for a championship
series Jinx monsoon
winning over fans and the judges by
being herself as well as several other
people I've been dead
I have been stopped quite a bit but
overnight success came with consequences
pressure to perform both on and off
stage left Jinx struggling with her own
identity
and using alcohol to cope I woke up one
morning and I said I feel like a
thermometer that just reached the top
I'm done
what made you realize you needed to have
that conversation I think
it was a big realization that I didn't
need it anymore
and a big part of that was really
celebrating my gender identity for
myself
publicly I'm an introverted person in an
extroverted career and alcohol helped
with that so stressful yeah but you know
what helps with that now Witchcraft and
therapy
she's replaced the ritual with actual
rituals I would just like look at all
the stones and pick up some and it's
always something you need in your life
you guys are gonna love this one I just
picked up the one that relieves anger
and whether you believe it works or it
works because you believe it Jinx says
it's really about learning to let things
go it is human nature to want to feel
connected to something more than just
what's going on right now especially
when things are kind of bleak
as drag has slayed and sashayed its way
into mainstream entertainment it's also
become a target with more than 140
attacks and threats on drag shows in the
last year including a mass shooting at a
performance in Colorado Springs do you
ever feel unsafe performing and do you
feel more unsafe now than you did 10
years ago I mean
no and and that's sad to say actually
but I mean I've been doing this for 20
years and I've felt these moments before
and I felt scared this is still an act
of Revolution because of what we still
face out there and even those who
appreciate the performance still
sometimes struggle to acknowledge or
understand the performers some of it
comes from a bad place but some of it I
think maybe doesn't so for people who
don't get it what would you say to them
what I tell my mom who's of a certain
generation you want to get it right so
you gotta start putting in the work you
know the way I approach talking to
people on this subject is with as much
patience and compassion as I believe
that person deserves so patience to the
point of participation yes I'm a
slightly competitive person when she
runs out of patience for the real world
Jinx goes virtual
you were at the finish line
the PlayStation goes everywhere she does
even on tour so that's now how I unwind
at the end of the night because
booze ain't sustainable
there is a big community of lgbtq plus
Gamers because you get to kind of decide
who you want to be in the game and for
maybe the first time who Jinx wants to
be has finally caught up to who she is
fine in the virtual world the theater
world
and most importantly real life we know
who's right it's the people wanting
people to be themselves and enjoy their
lives Life's too short to live it
pretending to be someone else
[Music]
life is just short to live it pretending
to be somewhere that's it that is the
Mantra that is the relatability for
everyone watching who she is what she
does and what she's overcome yes if
that's you know she said you don't have
to like drag you don't have to be into
what I'm doing but if some people are
and it brings them Joy life is kind of
hard just like let them enjoy it let
them enjoy it so I did bring a little
present for you guys what you got
um so when we were at the the Witchcraft
shop I purchased an extra anger Stone so
I don't know which person at the table I
was about to say are you making yourself
I'm making no judgments anger Stone
maybe we can give it to executive
producer Shawna Thomas I don't think
she's not angry either but you know who
could I vote on here
we'll give it to Patty okay
there we go perfect there we go uh if
you've never been to a drag show there
is a joy there is a fun spirited nature
that comes from it it's a blast
she has a lot of people cheering her on
what was opening night like opening
night was insane I mean I that audience
was there to see her and it was a moment
of Celebration it felt like for the
whole Community the couple in front of
us had flown from Portland where she's
from just to see her they brought her
flowers they brought her a card they
waited outside and if you saw that
opening shot they have to do that every
night they have to put up those
barricades she comes out signs all those
autographs and she stays until everybody
makes you want to go see it as for the
anger Stone someone who shall remain
nameless said you should keep it
John Tower
John Tower that's j-o-n Regina thank you
thank you